[Música]
bienvenidos a en 5 minutos con hoy nos
acompaña carlos eduardo pérez médico
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
de colombia hoy vamos a hablar de la
navidad en tiempos de pandemia doctor y
es que las autoridades sanitarias
recomiendan evitar las multitudes en
entornos cerrados y contacto cercano
como entonces celebrar la navidad segura
en medio de la pandemia el gran reto que
tenemos ahora es como celebrar la
navidad donde generalmente nos unimos
todos en medios de seguridad lo primero
es tratar de usar la virtualidad tratar
de evitar las aglomeraciones esas micros
reuniones porque ahí se puede establecer
el contagio y sobre todo con personas
mayores que son las más vulnerables
es un reto evitar las aglomeraciones y
celebrar con conectividad distinta la
navidad
cuáles serían las consideraciones a
tener en cuenta para las reuniones en
grupos reducidos de familiares y amigos
doctor
lo primero es tratar de evitar las
reuniones en lo que sea posible estas
reuniones si se llegaran a tener en
cuenta ojalá que sean en espacios
abiertos bien ventilados es importante
recordar que los espacios cerrados son
los que pueden mantener el coronario
sosteniendo entonces mantener los
espacios abiertos va a ser algo
importante y lo tercero evitar las
celebraciones religiosas en este momento
tenemos disponibles canales de facebook
de youtube donde se pueden seguir las
celebraciones religiosas para evitar
estas aglomeraciones y sobre viajar
doctor que tanto preocupa el alto nivel
de exposición durante estos traslados
y los viajes y los viajes en avión son
viajes seguros el viaje el problema es
el antes y el después del viaje
realmente nosotros no tenemos que dejar
si no es necesario es la hora de que
mantengamos un poco el alejamiento para
que nos recolectemos luego con mayor
fuerza
evite los viajes si son no son
necesarios evite los viajes familiares
es la hora de quedarse en casa de
celebrar individualmente o en grupos muy
pequeños y después de eso tendremos
oportunidad para reconectarnos con todos
sigamos con más recomendaciones
navideñas doctor si voy a ofrecer una
comida por ejemplo con reuniones de
pocas personas o si recibo huéspedes que
pasarán la noche en casa que debería ser
lo primero es que no deben tener
ningunos síntomas segundo no haberte una
exposición reciente a alguien con kobe
ser muy sin serios en estas en estas
navidades porque si alguien tiene alguna
sospecha que tiene enfermedad no puede
acercarse a estas a estos lugares de
reunión y es muy importante que nosotros
mantengamos en lo que sea posible el
alejamiento físico mantengamos una
alegría pero con distancia y que
tratemos de que estas reuniones sean en
espacios abiertos bien ventilados
ventanas abiertas puertas abiertas para
hacerlas de la forma más segura ojalá en
el día ni en la noche y así podemos
celebrar de una forma distinta nos dice
de la importancia de doctor de que no
tengamos síntomas ni los invitados es
posible incluso pedir que todos hagan
prueba de kobe 19 antes de reunirse con
la familia
si es algo que he oído recientemente que
para hacer la fiesta que traigamos toda
nuestra plan negativa el problema alan
es que cuando uno se hace la prueba
desde ese mismo momento se sabe si tiene
o no tiene pero al salir del sitio donde
tomar la prueba a uno le puede volver a
dar o no le puede dar con eso quiere
decir que la prueba no es vacuna no
asegura lo que permanece la
susceptibilidad es decir que al tener
una prueba negativa obviamente es que no
tiene en ese momento coronarios pero no
quiere que no lo vaya a tener durante el
momento que tenga la ruina por eso en
este aunque puede ser una medida sensata
y razonable para visitar a familiares de
alto riesgo pues es necesario evitar
y evitar este tipo de situación muy bien
doctor carlos eduardo pérez médico
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
de colombia muchas gracias por sus
recomendaciones profesionales de la
época navideña que está a la vuelta de
la esquina es por ello que vamos a
celebrar con cuidado la navidad en
tiempos de pandemia muchas gracias a
ustedes por su compañía ya lo sabe vea
más mucho más aquí en francés 24
[Música]